a few days ago I posted a game in which
I got my opponent into a really nasty
zuzuong position uh link below but if
you're not familiar with it's a type of
position in chess where basically you're
completely stuck and you have to
self-destruct and it's most common in
the end game but there are cases where
you can get into zuk zwang in the middle
game and in this video I want to share
probably the most famous zugswang in
chess history and this is a game that
was played about exactly a hundred years
ago actually I have to give credit to
International Master Junta Ikeda I saw a
tweet from him yesterday basically
celebrating the 100th anniversary of
this game I was played between Aaron
nimsovich with black pieces against
Frederick zamish and this is known as
The Immortal zugspon game and we're
going to see why but let's get into it
it was played I believe March 9th 2023
maybe March 10th I've seen conflicting
um conflicting information online but it
started with a very classical opening
Queen's Pawn going into a queen's Indian
zamish played G3 this is still a topical
opening uh a hundred years later
featured in many Grand Master games
and they went into a pretty solid line
not too much to say about this kind of
transposed into a queen's gamma decline
setup both sides have relatively nice
piece Harmony and why play the move here
in 95 which makes a ton of sense this is
a very typical especially with the
fiancado bishop to create the pin along
the long diagonal and I've played
similar setups as black and I found
these positions to be a little bit
uncomfortable just because white has
more space a bit more activity but we're
gonna see how nimsovich copes with this
uh starting the C6 just reinforcing D5
and after it takes takes Bishop F4 yeah
here it looks like white has a slight
Edge just happier pieces this bishop is
a little bit sad on B7 but I really
really like the way that nimsovich uh
kind of approach the next few moves
because he had a very clear plan in mind
uh which basically started with his next
move Pawn A6 and the point of this move
it kind of looks a little bit slow looks
like a waiting move but the ventral plan
is to expand with B5 and then maneuver
the Knight to C4 and it's a very typical
plan in the sort of opening for black to
kind of makes some Headway on the queen
side
uh White responded with Rook C1 uh Pawn
B5 was played Queen B3 and then Knight
to C6 and from here White made the first
mistake of the game white went ahead and
took the nylon C6 props fearing this
maneuver 95 would get temp on the queen
also the D4 Pawn is attacked so white
does have to address this threat now it
does turn out that white had a stronger
approach I've seen this game covered
throughout the years I know there's a
lot of videos featuring this game on
YouTube but I haven't seen the
possibility for whites mentioned in this
position until right before starting the
recording I was looking through a
stockfish and stockfish actually
recommends a really really cool move for
whites that leads to just immense
complications uh the move Knight takes
D5 now it's important to note that
stockfish did not exist 100 years ago or
even what like 20 years ago so um it
didn't really have the influence on the
classical games
now this would have led to a flurry of
Trades because after Knight takes D5 the
point is White's hitting the Knight on
C6 so if black takes back uh either way
and then the Knight will be lost on C6
but black can respond with Knight takes
D4 and then it's just a mess where so
many things are attached Queens are
attacked Knights attacked many different
ways white would have to play
um Knight takes E7 or Knight F6 here 97
would be preferable and then this was
the extent of my analysis with stockfish
where an engine says white has a slight
Edge but I think anything can still
happen from here
but let me show what happened in the
game
because white took on C6 and this is
somewhat of a positional mistake because
White made one two three moves with this
Knight just to trade it off so White's
essentially losing time and black is
still happy to uh recapture and even
though this bishop still looks sad we're
gonna see how black continues to improve
uh White plate H3 here after Queen D7
King H2
it became clear that White's not really
playing with a plan like these moves are
not too impressive and it's actually not
easy for white to find a clear plan here
like Bach is actually really really
solid and it's not clear how white
really makes meaningful progress or even
improves things in a meaningful way
so next several moves we're going to see
black really just improving and
expanding the position while whites
essentially just doesn't know what to do
next move was really nice Knight H5
hitting the bishop and also making way
for the F Pawn to move forward Bishop D2
is played and after F5 lack is just
expanding and white playlists add move
here Queen to D1 going all the way back
to the starting Square now this move was
played with intention to Target the
nylon H5
but after Pawn to B4 white is still
having to retreat uh Knight B1 played
and then Bishop to B5 so white really
wants to move the pawn to the Knight but
now the pawn is pinned to The Rook
so white played the move Rook G1 and if
we just look at the setup of White's
pieces like literally everything is just
super passive and uh black is having all
the fun puts the bishop on D6
and then here white played a really
interesting move and this move was
played with good intention Pawn to E4 at
first this move looks really powerful
because it's um it's preparing pong E5
but it's also hitting the undefended
Knight on H5
but it's very clear that nimsovich was
prepared for this move and he played
just a brilliant reply simply taking the
pawn losing the Knight but then winning
F2
so the position transforms where black
is now down a minor piece down a knight
for two Pawns
but White's position is just miserable
and the position becomes even more
difficult for white to play after Queen
G5 Rook af8 black is continually
improving King H1 getting off the
alignment of the rook and the bishop
but after Rook F5 Queen E3 Bishop D3
black pieces are kind of acting as a boa
constrictor just tying down white from
all directions and after Rook ce1
we are approaching the famous position
because
HERO Black played one more move
and zamish resigns
and there's actually probably a few
um probably many winning moves for black
but uh the move that was played was just
brutal nimsovich Unleashed Pawn H6
a very simple waiting move
and it turns out that white is just
completely completely stuck
and basically everything that white does
from this position will get punished in
some way
then this is the immortal zig's long
position after 25 moves uh nimsovich won
the game and I want to go through like
every single piece for white and show
why nothing can move first of all the
Knight is completely dominated uh only
two legal moves would result in Pawn
takes Knight
the bishop can't move forward these
squares are covered If It Moves backward
it cuts off The Rook so Bishop C1 would
just lose the Knight on B1
if we move on to this Rook uh F1 is
covered covered Three Times by The Rook
battery and the bishop can move to E2
and if it moves to D1 or C1 that moves
away from the E2 Square black would then
have rookie 2 trapping the White Queen
so this Rook is completely tied down
essentially to covering E2
this Rook has one legal move but it
would just blunder material and uh this
bishop also just doesn't have any
squares to go to now you may ask what
about the king and the pawns uh if the
king moves let's say to only legal move
to H2 then it walks into the pin the
bishop is now pinned which allows Rook 5
to F3 trapping the White Queen on E3 so
King stuck on each one if the pawn moves
to G4 this opens up a really nice tactic
essentially opens up the diagonal so now
that the bishop has scope to the H2
Square black has a similar idea Rook F3
again trapping the queen now if the
bishop takes its Checkmate in one Rook
H2
so G4 is not playable
and with the remaining pawn moves upon
H4 Pawn B3 Pawn A3 black can simply keep
waiting now if Pawn A3 just A5 takes
takes nothing really changes if Pawn B3
black can keep waiting Pawn H4 black
just keeps waiting maybe just move the
king back and forth and
um eventually white is in complete
paralysis and again for all the reasons
that I've addressed there's no moves and
if we go back to the position in which
white resigned after Pawn H6 the modern
engine very much confirms that white is
toast here engine gives about minus
eight in Black's favor it says that
white will eventually have to play
Bishop C1 and lose a knight and just
eventually lose everything
so I thought this was a really cool game
to share I really hope that people
enjoyed this analysis and I am thinking
about starting a series of videos where
I share games that I think every chess
player should know so let me know if you
want to see more content like this let
me know if you want to see any games
specifically to cover and be sure to
subscribe to stay tuned for more content
and I'll see you guys soon